[music]
>> I know myself
that if
I have to do without practice, this
portion I know very well. This lecture
without practice spontaneously you ask.
There are few lectures without a single
minute of revision, I will reach at
least more than 95%.
I know it. Other lectures,
if I don't do revision,
85%.
90%.
So, when there's no recording, who has
time? No recording, 1,000 people, no
revision, give lecture, 85 is only good.
Recording is there.
I have to do homework.
85 is not good. Recording means million
people are watching. Should be 95. Then
lecture I'm studying. Wait, why you're
studying?
You have given this lecture. Oh, I've
only given 20 times in my life.
I have to revise it for perfection.
So, I know my these few lectures if I've
given about 50 lectures in my life,
hypothetically.
Different topics. Topics are many, but
matter I know 50.
From this 50, these eight I can
with preparation, without preparation,
will reach above 95%.
These lectures without preparation, 85.
Some lectures without preparation, only
50. Why? I've given 5 years back. I've
not done muraja.
I'll quote references may not be all.
So, I as a dying know my own plus and
negative points.
So, knowing your weakness also is
important.
Knowing your positive points is also
important. Now,
the advantage is those lectures which I
don't know very well, in question answer
time I'm using only part of it. Those
which I know well, I'm using it more
strongly. We shall come to the
techniques of handling question answer
sessions later on. Main is number one,
Allah's help.
Number two, striving and struggling.
Then is technique. Technique is nothing
great. The main thing is Allah's help.
But normally,
what I prefer, that every human being
has certain things which he is better
than the other things.
And
scientifically, there are two things.
One is something called as numerals, 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8. Something which is called
as words. Something which is digits and
numerals.
So, some people are well versed with
recollecting numerals. Numbers so and
so. Some people can memorize telephone
numbers
very well. I remember before mobile was
there, I knew 100, 200, 300 telephone
numbers. But now, I don't even know 10.
I don't know my wife's number. Why? It's
there in the memory, so why should I use
my memory?
I stopped memorizing later on because
that time the mobile wasn't there.
Those numbers which I knew before, the
office number and the home number which
is the same, it is there in my permanent
memory. Even if I want to remove, I
can't remove.
So, now if you ask me,
I don't know the mobile number of a
manager also.
Huh? Zakir Naik doesn't know? Why? Huh,
Zakir Naik doesn't know. Why should I
waste my time?
When I have the memory of my mobile, 128
GB which I'm not using, why should I
use? Correct?
If something happens, there's a problem.
I know by heart of my home and of the
office. I can retrieve it.
If I really think how many numbers do I
know, mobile numbers? At a time I knew a
few hundred.
Now, not even 10.
I don't know the vehicle number of mine.
I don't At the time there was I knew my
motorcycle at one. Now, vehicle I don't
know.
Why should I?
If I put junk in my hard disk,
it will get packed. Once it's full,
nothing can enter. I have to empty it.
So, everyone has a capacity.
Irrespective whether you have 1 GB, you
may have 10 GB, you may have 1 TB. It
can get full.
So, see to it. Don't stuff your memory
with things which are not required.
If you ask me songs, I don't know songs.
Fine, what I have learned in school,
Jack and Jill went up the hill. I mean,
I know that because it's all in my
permanent memory now.
It's gone. It can't come out. I know it.
Now, something like permanent memory is
not utilizing much of your space because
it is in low resolution. If it goes in
the permanent memory,
there's something like when we store
See, when we store all these 4K and 8K,
what we do? We archive in LTO. It goes
in a different compressed uncompressed
form. So, uncompressed in the permanent
memory requires less space. It's gone. I
can't remove it if I want to remove
also. It may damage my hard disk. Let it
be there.
What you remember what you did when you
were a kid at the age of 10, it's there.
What you did 1 month back, you may
forget.
So, try and put this knowledge in your
permanent memory.
Tell you frankly what I gave in the
morning,
I did not have an idea what I'm going to
speak.
I would this book okay, fine. I go
retrieve. I didn't learn. If you'd ask
me I thought how much time? I don't
know. Maybe take 1 hour. Why give 1 hour
15 minutes? When I started I thought 1
hour 15 minutes is this.
I could speak for a day or 2 days. All
this is from the permanent memory.
There's nothing from the
fresh memory. Put it in your permanent
memory. Permanent memory requires less
space.
It becomes compressed.
Compressed means
more data and less space. But to
retrieve you have to press the button.
It gets uncompressed and comes back.
Understood?
If you put it in your temporary memory,
it is
uncompressed. Anything uncompressed
requires more space. I'm sure you may be
aware a little bit of IT. Correct?
Little bit. All of you may be aware Are
you aware or not what I'm talking the
lingo I'm talking? Yes or no? Who is
with me? Raise your hand. Uh because
today everyone even you are not an IT
manager and neither am I. You know
mobile is there even the kid knows what
is
little bit extra is compressed and
uncompressed.
So how the computer works
if you allow me to call the human beings
a computer, it is the best computer in
the world.
Allah's creation.
Only thing whether you use it or abuse
it is yours.
YOU ASK A KID
LATEST SEE FILM SONGS THAT ARE THERE.
SMALL KID.
WHAT IS THE BENEFIT IN AAKHIRA?
OUR SCHOOL kids
Quran, Hadith, Alhamdulillah.
Kid is the same.
What you put in is yours.
So Allah has given you this brain.
For a normal human being, average human
being to remember it's very easy.
If you're below average it's a different
question. And I believe all of you Masha
Allah are above average people.
It's very easy, but
when you have reached a level if you
have done the course
when you finish it, it is in your
temporary memory, do little bit more
hard work and put it in your permanent
memory. Now, when it goes in the
permanent memory as compressed,
you can keep more data in it.
Only thing you should keep on using the
code the password to retrieve it.
Keep on practicing. Initially have to
practice every day, then maybe once a
week, then once it goes in the permanent
memory, khalas.
Maybe everything will not go. 80% That's
good. Alhamdulillah, 80%. 80% also you
could it's good.
20% after you do practice.
So, everyone has an ability
either to recollect the digits well
or the words well.
Some people have both.
So, when giving references, I personally
it's my personal choice.
When I give references,
I say first the name of the surah. Surah
Al Imran.
Chapter number three,
verse number so and so.
That's my style.
Someone will say, "No, I don't want to
say verse. I want to say ayat number."
No problem. Surah Al Imran. Chapter
number three, ayat number
110. Both are correct.
Why I use verse? Because I speak even
with non-Muslims. Non-Muslims understand
what is this ayat. Verse is
understood. It's a chapter and a verse,
a big para and a small para. So, I
prefer using but if you say ayat, I've
got no problem.
When I say Surah Imran, I understand.
When I say chapter, the non-Muslim
understands.
That's
it's part of a book chapter.
In that there is a smaller part called
as verse.
He knows it's a reference.
So, I prefer when I quote,
I quote the surah name.
Surah Nisa,
chapter number four,
verse number
176.
Verse number 11. Verse number 12.
Whatever it is.
So therefore while practicing
if you have to practice, say the surah
name first, surah Al Imran, chapter
number three, and then give the
translation. While giving talks, we
don't give the Arabic, but
I prefer the translation. Why?
Now,
how many people know Arabic as a
language? Raise your hand.
Arabic as a language?
One, two, three.
Arabic as a language means you can
converse very well. If you're a person
who can debate in a language, he knows
the language well. A person who can give
a talk in the language, he knows the
language well.
I know Arabic, but I don't know Arabic
as a language. I know Arabic.
As a language means I can give a lecture
in that language.
If you can fight in that language, that
means you know the language well.
Correct?
How many people know Arabic as a
language?
One, two.
Uh see, four hands went, not two hands
went. Four hands were there.
There were four hands raised.
When I said there's a language in which
you can speak, in which you can debate,
in which you can give a lecture, is a
language you know well.
So out of four hands, two hands went
down.
In our school, masha Allah, Islamic
International School,
we give important I don't know Arabic as
a language. I understand sure sure what
you tell.
I converse, but I don't know it as a
language.
It's my drawback.
And Allah knows best why. I tried a lot.
I did jihad. Allah knows best. Sometimes
there are secrets Allah knows better
than us.
Allah says in the Quran, what you like,
you may not know will not be good for
you. What you hate may be good for you.
Allah knows that we don't know. Allah
knows the best. But alhamdulillah,
alhamdulillah, summa alhamdulillah,
through my lectures, thousands of people
have learned Arabic as a language.
Alhamdulillah, summa alhamdulillah.
It's a language which I believe a dahi
should know.
Power that you have if you understand
Arabic as a language, time doesn't
permit us to go into details.
Now, why do I say Surah Nisa, chapter 4,
the woman? Why? Now, because we don't
know Arabic as a language.
Those who know Arabic as a language,
they need not use the translation.
They know it as a language. They know
the language.
And we put emphasis on Lugat Fasih in
our school.
Lugat Fasih means the pure Arabic,
Fasih.
Pure.
Something like colloquial Arabic. "Kayfa
haluka?" "Alhamdulillah." "Ana bi
khair." This, you go. You want to do a
job, you do a 3-weeks training, you'll
know about it. But that will not make
you understand the Quran.
Some people, when you quote the words of
the Quran, they can translate because
that is
just an idea of the language.
So, most of the people that go to
Islamic universities, unless it's a
purely Arabic-based.
You go to India, they may teach you in
Urdu.
They know Arabic because they know the
gist of it that many words of Urdu are
in Arabic common, so they can give a
gist of it.
But they can't give the root word with
the various meanings.
So, knowing Arabic as a language is
different than having understanding and
faham of the language.
>> [music]
[singing]
>> Allah.
Allah.
Antal Halim.
Ar-Rahman, As-Sattar, Malikul Mulk,
Al-Ghaffar, Al-Wahhab, Al-Mannan,
Al-Muta'al.
Allahu, Allahu, ya Rabbi, ya Allah.
Allahu, ya
Rabbi, ya